hi how are we are we well was it a good
break did we get food are we refreshed
yes really
let's try that again yes there we go
excellent
my name is Degas that's pronounced like
contagious and I make that very easy
because I get a lot of is your name
chaos is it Texas is it you know I get a
lot of mispronunciations here's here's a
way of making it easy it is like
contagious don't worry I'm not sick I'm
not gonna give you anything besides
hopefully a good talk about JavaScript
and it's welcoming nature day-to-day I
work at a data science platform called
Conte amo and what we do is we build
very rich expressive user interfaces
that interact with things like machine
learning models and AI
to enable our customers to make better
decisions from their data essentially
build decision tools I'm here to in the
world I'm here today to talk to us about
JavaScript especially it's do I need to
do something or especially how
javascript is a language is is helpful
in welcoming and and more hospitable and
accommodating to newcomers across the
board from beginners to intermediates to
more advanced engineers I'd really like
to get the slides fixed throw me off a
bit let's see maybe should I not touch
anything
Hey okay what tech guys are on the way I
guess I can just continue talking so
where are we today we're gonna talk
about jaws the title of the talk is from
you can't - you can the welcoming nature
of JavaScript from you can't - you can
the welcoming nature of JavaScript have
you ever felt like JavaScript has been
described or in some ways dismissed or
reduced as it's kind of a toy language
it's kind of a it's a little bit brittle
it's a little bit shaky oh we have
slides see that's cool can we hear it
really
all right well thank you sir so that the
title is called from you can't - you can
the welcoming nature of JavaScript right
and so we want to talk about how
JavaScript through various language
syntax features is just something that
is so approachable and hospitable and
then we will talk a little bit about my
experience to make my point about
JavaScript maybe being a language that
some consider brittle and maybe not as
robust I'd like to share with you a
quote from a friend of mine
this quote is I think a good summation
of how we think about JavaScript
seriously there we go
this is a heavy paraphrase of what a
friend of mine has said and it's heavy
because it was way worse the original
text let me tell you he's a scholar
engineer and really talented but fact of
the matter is some of the more I'd say
opinionated languages have this opinion
about JavaScript my goal today is to
examine some points of criticism about
JavaScript and say hey maybe that is not
a bug but maybe that's a feature do you
understand
are you with me maybe that's not a
weakness but maybe it's a strength maybe
it's not a disadvantage but an advantage
I want to talk to us particularly about
four things and then if we have some
time at the end I'd like to kind of
share just a bit of my story and
experience with JavaScript with that I'd
like to for two seconds give us some
context for those of us who maybe
haven't heard top two seconds about the
history of JavaScript so in the
beginning the web platform was really
immature or just just beginning and you
know the future of the web at the time I
think I think it was the 80s I'm not
even sure was was foreseen as something
that would be powered by Java right Java
applets and browsers would be web 2.0
Wow how cool would that be right and and
meanwhile Netscape Brendan Eich invented
this language for the web platform that
would be
expressive and powerful and would really
see the web forward I read that this
language took three weeks to come up
with and and I've heard that it is it
was a rush to delivery now how many of
us have written rushed to delivery code
I don't even need to say I mean we know
that's like right I think while some
would say that that part of JavaScript
is maybe what makes it weak or unique I
would say that may have been one of the
happiest accidents if it was an accident
in the history of our time and that's
the reason I put this slide up there now
let's get to the four things number one
I can already see some of the typescript
people in the room judging me but but
let me tell you I think dynamic typing
with JavaScript is while criticize is
something that is weak and that creates
brittle applications I have honestly not
seen a more welcoming construct mainly
because static typing as it stands is
extra syntax and and there's a lot to
keep track of I mean this is from
feedback from friends of mine who were
journalists architects graphic designers
with not a lot of web dev or computer
science experience all of them wanting a
change from the industry that they're
studied and guess which language they
found their home and I tell you what it
was not reason ml or typescript
JavaScript by its very nature of dynamic
typing was was the language of choice I
believe this is the reason I believe
through the dynamic nature of the
language what you get is the ability to
go from zero to oh my gosh it's working
in a fraction of the time it would
normally take I would also say that
dynamic typing is educational absolutely
educational and what I mean by that is
it teaches you the need for static
typing right how many of you have been
bitten by implicit coercion or you try
and do a computation and you get an an
or the
the various types of errors that can
occur with JavaScript simplicity
coercion because of its dynamic type
system I would say what happens then is
something really cool and something I
believe is unique to the JavaScript
community
you see JavaScript as a syntax I would
say is really really really friendly for
the reasons we discussed but I would say
that's two sides of the same point the
other site being the helpful supportive
inclusive community that I'm looking at
right now if someone's bitten by it by a
typing error in JavaScript or just a
computation that's impossible
what's the next step you turn to Stack
Overflow or github or something or
discord and you find a community that
says oh wow that's because you know
you're changing this thing and whatever
the cause may be and you learn I I grew
up in a in a school setting where where
information was ingested and then
regurgitated practically and
professionally so you you learn things
and then you just do it in your job
that's just the way it's always been
that's that's what we've learned whereas
I would argue when you when you've been
bitten by a few dynamic type problems
you actually learn the need and the
importance of it and then use it wisely
number two this is a quote that that
should not have happened we'll talk
about that in a second number two this
is an excerpt from Crockford comm by the
author of the book called javascript the
good parts Douglas Crockford he is I
would say one of the greatest
contributors to the JavaScript community
I mean he used to work for Yahoo and
created a UI kit and all kinds of
goodies and this is what he says about
Java scripts API is from the browser and
from node he says javascript is also
coupled with the Dom horrendous API this
was before no js' there's a lot of
confusion about where javascript ends
and the Dom begins and and while I would
agree with the second part I would say
actually I don't see why the Dom
particularly is a horrendous API in fact
the Dom I would say is a reason I have a
job but the Dom is the reason for many
of our careers here especially if you
work with like reactor
you or something we have a react fan
view fan we have a UI fan I would argue
api's at least for me and other
engineers who have started have been
just these building blocks right from
which you can show a pop-up or a modal
dialog or a accept user input using
window dot from you can fetch data using
the fetch API it's declared it's kind of
like there was a talk in CSS conf with
with declarative CSS where it display
flex is a declarative algorithm the API
is I would say give you this this tool
set in the browser and in node that gets
you up and running really fast it's part
of the welcoming nature of JavaScript I
will admit for me as a junior engineer I
I tried to use window in node and and
and it of course gave me an error and I
was like wait what Windows not kind of
just a function you can or an object you
can use in JavaScript I confuse it for
syntax absolutely but that again was
where the community shone and I learned
and I was able to learn in fact API I've
spent a lot of time talking about api's
and and really this talk is largely
community based it's not very technical
but I thought you know since I'm talking
about API so much I might as well use
one and so I I wanted to build something
right and so what I ended up doing was
thinking about what can I build and I
thought about well you know I really
like talking in case you can't tell and
and I really like people and I don't
have to like hide behind this podium
here and change my slides or use a
clicker and so I just thought I could
build something that as I'm talking it
would follow me through my slides and
that's basically what's been happening
this whole time
hello my name
it's just the JavaScript ecosystem is so
rich with these api's so I built this
thing I put it on github
it's called praise and it's it's very
it's open source it's very experimental
please do not use it in production it's
only supported in Chrome
but it's literally just to make a point
and that point is JavaScript is
welcoming a praise was the praise right
see it's experimental anyway that's
that's the project and so I would say
API is Allah how long did this take i
sat next to my girlfriend this beautiful
young lady here took me for hours on a
Saturday afternoon and I was I was added
so I even made react bindings for it
because why not all of that song github
number three JavaScript i've been heard
i've been heard javascript criticized as
a an opinionated language you can kind
of just write whatever style of code you
want and and that's that's the language
you can write class-based
object-oriented polymorphic inheritance
style code or you could write stateless
functional immutable code with monads
flying around that looks like math and
there's no real it doesn't push you into
a style I've heard this from golang
engineers right who if you've looked at
go code it's really just it looks very
homogeneous but I would actually say if
you take a peek under the hood of
JavaScript what you'll find is that is
in fact opinionated like I've written
class-based object-oriented polymorphic
inheritance style code and there's a use
case for that absolutely but under the
hood what you end up getting is
functions and objects and things that
use prototype allocation and so this
would lead me to think JavaScript is
kind of sort of leaning towards more of
a functional language you get
first-class functions you get recursion
out of the box there's a star there
because I know I know not everything is
an object or a function but you catch my
drift and then in a team you can kind of
conventional eyes the other functional
best practices you can have
pure functions you can have immutable
data structures on and on and on I could
go I would say JavaScript is easier this
way when I tried writing code kind of
Java style what ended up happening was I
felt like I was going up an escalator
that was moving down you tracking with
me it felt almost like I was fighting
the language and and when I when I used
the language the way I would say it was
designed things got a lot easier the
last thing I'll say is really it's a it
was a point of controversy for a little
bit last year I'm not gonna say much
about it because it in my opinion it is
incredible it is the greatest mechanic a
compiler can have I guarantee you lastly
we'll talk about my slides don't change
see it's experimental don't use it in
production lastly we'll talk about this
automatic semicolon insertion is such a
blessing for beginning developers
honestly like have you ever worked in
another language left off a semicolon
and what happened the compiler yells at
you you know in your like minute why why
not allowed to make a mistake yeah yeah
JavaScript if it's someone just learning
it what does it do it just says I see
what you're trying to do I got you yeah
if there's one thing you get from this
talk let it be that javascript is your
bro or sis or whatever we gender-neutral
and so those are the four things that
that I think really help JavaScript be
this language that is so easy to adopt
across the board about is I'll say one
more thing as I've learned and grown
into a more seasoned engineer I would
recommend leave your semicolons on
honestly it's good as a starting out
step to maybe have no optional but but
what you're doing is you're fighting the
compiler under the hood by not having
them now that that's out of the way
let's shift gears a little bit and and
I'd like to talk briefly about my
journey with
javascript because you see in many ways
is the journey of from you can't - you
can
I was born with with a disability I was
born with a disease as I said in the
beginning I'm not contagious don't worry
but but it's still a disease and it is
life-threatening and I've been told I
have the worst kind of it basically the
condition is called hemophilia do not
confuse that with homophobia but
hemophilia is a disease where where once
I start bleeding I do not stop until I
lose all my blood and die and so I mean
I can see some of your engineers in the
room I'm go like well then just don't
get cut problem solved dude it's not
rockets but let me tell you internal
bleeding is something that is far more
common than external bleeding and so if
you've walked today if you came with a
backpack I guarantee you you have
started bleeding at some point into your
knees or your ankles or into your elbows
but you stop so you don't even notice
I've been in the emergency room
literally by opening a heavy door I by
climbing stairs I've literally spent
weeks in the emergency room and so this
you can see by this how you can get a
lot of you cans all right you can't play
sports you can't ride a bicycle I have a
bicycle to this day I have no idea what
to do with it it just sits there should
probably sell it who wants to buy it but
anyway I really I I so there's a lot of
you can't and that started to change
when my brother who's healthy
he went to HTML class and and when I was
8 years old he came home and he showed
me he was like look what I learned and
he was he wasn't as interested but I was
like you kidding me
I couldn't make a UI and and I was so
interested and so what ended up
happening was he would go to school my
parents would go to work and I would be
alone at home all day Air day most of
the year in an entire school year I
would attend 19 days
cool the rest of the time I'm alone at
home doing what well there's so many
games you can play and cartoons you can
watch and candy you can eat until you
get bored and when you're bored I've
learned you do what interests you and
for me this was code and so I started
writing some code and made a couple
websites as a child and and I was in
magazines I mean if there's a child
making websites in a small town people
here I was in a few magazines and and
then my parents god bless them they did
the best thing they knew to do they put
me in an advanced program for
object-oriented C++ at age 10 I still
have the diploma and and I'm like I
don't remember any of it
right as a 10 year old I'm sitting there
with all kinds of includes at the top of
the file hash include' cone ëoh or
something like this and I'm like cone is
there ice cream involved in this program
I honestly had no idea the compiler
would yell at me for literally
everything and as a ten year old I'm
sitting there and I'm going why is it
yelling at me I'm writing code is this
another thing I can't do I thought
programming was my thing this was the
one people have applauded me I've been
you can't you can't you can't and no I
thought I could eventually I got back
into JavaScript as it as it evolved and
you know things like like prototyping
script Acula came on the scene it and
then mootools and jQuery and things
started picking up some traction
eventually won an award for web
development in my hometown and and not
long after the job came and another job
and I'm interviewing all the sudden for
a position in Germany move here and now
let me tell you I've access to the best
healthcare I have ever received I go
running I lift weights I've climbed
mountains I go rafting in a river it's
insane and all the sudden most of the
you can't have become the you can
largely because thank you yeah I can go
for it
largely largely because of the welcoming
nature of JavaScript let me tell you we
have a language that is inclusive that
is tolerant that will not entangle your
mind with intersection types and
discriminated unions and generics and
while these are good things I think
there's a time and a place we have a
language that is inclusive that is easy
of the other side of the coin we have a
community can we hear it for the
community we have a community I mean
look around you this looks like the
United Nations here right we have a
community that is inclusive that is
tolerant that is mostly vegan I'll leave
you I'll leave you with this I have
thoroughly enjoyed our time together
I've thoroughly enjoyed working even
with the organizers of this conference
to make it a wonderful time or they've
given me a wonderful time more than I
haven't even organized anything don't
get me wrong
but but I'll leave you with this I think
we have the potential to make the
language what it is you how many of you
have heard the tc39 talk right exactly
tc39 shapes the language and there's an
open standard is an open source project
with proposals contribute get involved
you have the power to make the language
what you want it to be if you don't want
a code you have the power to make the
community what it is you have the power
I leave up the slide for a praise and in
fact and if any of you are interested it
should change if it doesn't change
whatever but thank you very much that's
my that's my talk